i was young man i was yeah i didn't want
to be on mtv like i was you know i mean
i guess i did
but i was just 19. it's not like i was
making any life choices
right right and then the next thing you
know i was like oh if you don't think
that i have a talent well
i'm going to do the hardest job in
[Music]
town and i'm gonna do it the best and
that started like just getting into my
head like you don't think i have talent
well um let's see if i do
you know right yeah so so then i just
got into stand up and i always like
making people laugh like i used to do a
similar thing when i was a child
at the lunch table we'd get some kids
who were minnows or a couple might have
been minnows and
a couple kids that were well you know
when we get there and sit i'm gonna
make them drink milk and then tell jokes
and do stuff and to tell one of us
just blew milk out of their face you
know
and if you get some straight up just
couple minnows boys i'm straight up saw
it off humans
you get them to do you get them straight
up blow leche out there dumb dude
[Laughter]
that's america right there you know what
i'm saying
and that's when i knew i was like oh i
got some kind of a gift here
you know i almost blew the throat out of
this one boy
almost threw the this just almost blew
the throat out of this
this one boy named tot trt with his name
kind of a bad name too to be mentally
challenged
also easy for him to spell and i'm not
joking that's what his father said and
um easy for him to spell backward and
forward same name
taught
[Laughter]
so oh that's true man was this guy's
real
his name was todd why are you still
laughing at him
it's just a funny sounding name that's
all i'm saying you're right yeah it was
pretty funny i guess
yeah well you know let's talk about todd
sometimes he would just say t.o.t was
his name but i knew it was tot
yeah he would try to spell it out and
you know like he was tricking me
yeah so so did you do like the open
mic circuit in l.a yeah started doing
open mics here like at marty's or where
like
uh meltdown and stuff no they had a
place over on the west side of town i
lived
i was sleeping under a buddy of mine had
a bed and i was sleeping under his bed
for 150
a month oh wow and sometimes even in his
bed sometimes
when he would be out of town or when he
would leave for work i'd climb up into
his bed dude
and i've never been heavily homosexual
but i will say this
that there's nothing really gayer than
getting into a man's warmth after he's
already left the room you know and
climbing up into his bed
i mean you don't even really know that
much am i still catching that hit off of
his temperature you know
it's true man you go over to somebody's
house dude you don't know that much when
they leave the room and get the
get out of their bed you get into their
bed
you never told them that though that
shouldn't make a man out of you fast
dude or it won't
you find out who's who pretty quick when
you're doing stuff like that yeah yeah
you know bobby just gets set in some way
in some in some spots of comfortability
well with his jokes i think with
everything you know he likes to pee on
the balcony
you know and he likes to just be
comfortable yeah and that's okay i've
been there dude i went the bed law is
probably
31 and outside areas
but he uh you know i think he likes to
be comfortable and sometimes you get
comfortable in your set